uh I am curious for both of you um what
are you actually most excited for fans
to see in the prequel series
for me it's exciting the fans by
showing the elves In a Different Light
um there you know for me they're the one
of the most fascinating things in
Sakowski books was how how did they fall
so far from being such a a strong sort
of species on the continent how does it
get to the point where the pre agrarian
and barely functioning and are having
trouble reproducing how how do they fall
and getting to see them at their height
um in a very different light with
different sort of costuming and they're
seeing what their architecture was like
and their music and Science and Magic
how it's very different to the world of
The Witcher so it's surprising but still
complementary to that world that's the
bit I'm excited about
I mean I could I could list out a
million things as like with your mom
that I'm excited about you know things
that will lead into the main series but
just stepping back because I've I've
watched the series many times and I
think it's amazing
um I'm really excited for fans to hear
the original music I have to say um
declan's is a musician his uh skills are
all over Witcher season one and two and
the fact that we get such beautiful
songs that I believe are going to stick
in people's heads
um they're so emotional they're so
heart-wrenching as a fan I would say
that's the thing I'm most excited for
everyone to see I'm curious Lauren with
the popularity of the series
um and this obviously being very
successful this uh this prequel I mean
you guys did a great job with it do you
think that there will be more prequel
series or spin-offs is that something
that like Netflix is talking about with
live action stuff
I mean I think the stories that we have
in our back pockets the things that
subkovsky sets out for us that I will
never be able to cover in the main
Witcher series I think the possibilities
are kind of endless I think it really
depends on the continued appetite for
fans to show up and see more of these
stories and it fits into the world of
Sakowski as well because he's the king
of little short contained stories that
feed the world but isolated by
themselves exist on their own so the
idea of side quests and sideshows and
prequels all fits into the world of The
Witcher in my mind anyway last question
for you
um obviously you're changing the cast
with season four of the Witcher and I'm
curious how does that possibly change
the filming schedule with because
Henry's schedule is always you know a
little busy and I'm just curious with
Liam do you think he'll be filming that
sooner
um than maybe do you know what I mean
like have you already thought about that
yeah yeah but that is so far away for us
right now and uh you know that's going
to be up to powers that be honestly I'm
really excited for Witcher season four I
think it's gonna be fantastic I can't
wait to get started we're not there so
right now I just really want to keep the
focus on blood origin and all this
amazing work